[Music]
before you watch another comedy sequel
released 10 plus years after the
original
that will probably suck ass revisit the
modern fairy tale that
asks what if one of those nigerian
prince scams were real
damn i knew i should answer that email
coming to america
get ready for a series of late 80s snl
sketches held together by the nuclear
charisma of eddie murphy
when you think of garbage think of akin
that has him cast against hype as a
naive romantic
then makes up for it by casting himself
as everyone else too
in a formula that works 100 of the time
of the time in hell before one such
poison out of another man's ass
meet akeem yet another royal immigrant
who comes to the us to take our jobs
seriously it's an epidemic but he's
surprisingly humble for a guy whose face
is on money
and surprisingly righteous for a guy
with his own dick washer
the royal penis is clean your highness
making him one of the only spoiled rich
kids to turn out pretty cool
i think the director can manage that so
congratulations to whichever
kind-hearted nanny raised the king
because it was definitely not his
parents
journey to a wakanda known as a munda
a fictional african kingdom thought up
by white guys
rich beyond all comprehension with a
bachelor prince who's shy around girls
and the king dresses like a big cat but
a king will gladly leave the fame and
fortune behind for a chance to move to
new york and blatantly steal this
porsche muck's girlfriend
yeah i know he's a jerk but i guess bro
code into the border huh
along for the ride to the big apple is
semi his
ballet personal trainer human toy
if his job is to be the royal best
friend he's terrible at it
i feel like a complete idiot i doubt we
will ever find your queen what's not
fair is me doing manual labor
do you realize i have not had sex since
we got to america things are going so
well with lisa i do not care
but every king needs his queen and lisa
is a hard-working
independent woman with principles that
she'll quickly sell out for a bigger
house like the rest of the boomers
if you like we can give it all up now
and experience james earl jones as you
love to see him most being someone's dad
you may not be my father sir but you
will always be my daddy
witness a truly impressive parade of
soon-to-be-famous actors
from samuel l jackson getting a start as
this bad mother ever anybody move out
blow your
head off to cuba gooding jr as boy
getting haircut
to a young paula abdul choreographing
the dance scenes
even the royal penis lady got work if
eddie and arsenio played fewer parts we
could have had don cheadle in our lives
a whole decade sooner
so sit back and enjoy eddie murphy's 80s
comedy about africans
that's aged better than his other 80s
i have to go off to the woods of africa
and find me some crazy naked zebra
that takes you back to a golden era when
these two were on top of the world
before they stopped working all the time
and went off to enjoy their families and
spend their millions
wait celebrities are allowed to do that
will somebody please tell bruce willis
we didn't know whether to burn it or put
in a museum
i'm sure they said the same thing about
me welcome to the party pal
it ended many years ago you can rest now
starring the nutty successor
burger queen and twins
the founder city slicker 2
legend of curly's glow and twin
robert mugabe and sir this is a wendy's
the prince's bride
since this takes place in a shared
universe does that mean that eddie has
an identical millionaire twin named
valentine
it was agatha all along if the universe
is so big
then why won't it fight me this is
getting out of hand
now there are two of them harder
better faster stronger
harder better faster stronger